Hello and welcome to this course, Perception and Environment Query System.
This course will be for Unreal Engine 5.6, but the content is valid all the way through version 5.
Now to start with, there are a few things that we would like you to come out of this course
knowing. The first one being having a good understanding of how the AI perception system
works and also to be able to set it up from scratch and get it working with.
We're going to be using state trees but this would work with behavior trees as well.
We also are going to go over the theory and get up and working an example of an
environmental query system which is used for the more complicated AI decision making.
So we're going to run through both of these systems and they do a similar thing in just
a slightly different way. What we will be doing though is we will be working with a project
file that will have a number of different examples and exercises in it. So I really do
recommend that you download the project file. We'll have a quick look at that as part of this
video at the end, but it will make the course make a lot more sense and you'll get a lot more
out of it. So let's talk about theory of the AI perception component. So what is the AI
perception system? Well this is built to mimic human perception. So it is a component
that you can add to your actor which will go away and it will have a different setup
for each different perception such as sight, hearing, touch and more. They all require
a little bit of a different tweaking but we're going to go through some of the most common
ones and go through how to set them. Now this has two different classes that we're going
to use and need to know about. The first one is the AI perception component. Now this
is what you would attach to your player or your pawn or your character and this is going
to be what does the work. It is a actor component. It needs to be attached to usually
a child of the pawn class. Then we have the AI perception stimulus source component.
Again another actor component but this doesn't do as much as the other one. It primarily
allows you to register a actor as a stimulus source. We're going over that in detail.
Now when we're working with AI perception most of the work is going to be done by overriding
a number of events attached to the AI perception component. Now this has about four or five
events however a lot of them will fire at the same time because they will just provide
a different subset of the data. So they will provide different amounts of data depending on
which one they are. For our needs we are going to be using but one of these and that is the
on target perception updated. The second class is the AI perception stimuli source.
The AI perception component registers things in slightly different ways but
when we're talking about sight which is one of the most common ones
it will automatically register anything that inherits from the pawn class.
Now if you've got something that does not inherit from the pawn class yet you want it
to be seen and register with sight all you need to use is this component. We will be doing this
too in an exercise where we will be setting up a pickup so that it can be seen and the AI can
and interact with it. Now the other thing that's worth noting is some of the stimuli are not
really registered in the same way by either being a pawn or having the source connected to it
but by manually reporting an event. So in this case if you want to report a noise touch or
damage event you're best off using one of these nodes. The perception event is talking about sight
in this case which can sort of manually force the perception rather than adding a component.
Now hopefully if you've downloaded the project you should get something that looks a little bit
like this. Now one of the oddities with this project is we've got something that's called
the train gate. Now you may see this when you fire up the engine as a free-floating box.
What I suggest you do is drag this up and place it in the top right hand corner here
and shrink it down so that you can just see the forwards and backwards buttons.
The other thing that we're going to need to have is the content drawer.
Now I am going to dock this in the layout so that it is easy for you to see
and this allows us to have a look at the trading aid. You'll see as we move through this
it will allow us to move through the different exercises and examples and it will also
pass to the required files that we'll need to use. This really does make it slightly easier
to navigate the project. If you've closed it down or it didn't open for some reason
in this links at the top here you'll see there is a button to training aid
for which I close that down should just open it up again give you access to it.
And that brings us to the end of our first video. In the next video we're going to be
jumping straight into an exercise where we will set up the Perception component.